did he call it a friendship we're living
the vida loca how you letting her out of
a house like that secure myself it's
alright
yep it's been 20 years since JLo wore
that dress
changing the red carpet game at the 2000
Grammy Awards which got ET thinking what
the hell else happened that year luckily
we were there and what better place to
start them with that dress tell me first
off for this outfit Chris achi I still
gotta tell him with it and I had to have
it for the Grammys
J Lo's Green Versace dress was so fierce
and searched for on the internet that it
actually inspired Google Image Search oh
yeah we should mention in 2000 jennifer
was dating P Diddy are you guys gonna
have battling Grammys after that after I
mean so if she don't win I'll enter one
of mine good then there was this
Christina Aguilera and Britney Spears is
battle for Best New Artist both pop
stars were nominated for the high honor
and slayed the red carpet Brent in a
Marilyn Monroe inspired look and
Christina
blinged out in Versace this is the first
dress that I looked at and it was the
first I was I knew it was the dress I
had to wear tonight I will cherish it
forever
Christina beat out Brett taking home
that Grammy gold I was shocked
out of my mind I was you know I was
preparing to have my oh it's okay I lost
loser look you know what I read but
whenever they said my name I was like oh
my god like I had no speech prepared
nothing I'm afraid to see the tape
playback every single artist if you look
at it but that was nominated had like
you know at least two three four singles
out before you know I even had what a
girl wants which is my second single out
I was just so shocked that one single
was able to do it oh and bonus fact at
the time Christina and Carson Daly were
totally crushing on each other Carson's
such a sweetheart
I mean like I know that he supported me
as an artist and
I just think he's so great and
down-to-earth you know what I mean every
time I see him it's so cool we we
definitely have a chemistry together I
mean I think he's cute you know and I've
heard through the grapevine that he
thinks I'm cute to him so I just think
that he's a really cool guy
and we just haven't had enough time to
maybe get to know each other we had
rumors of the two of us dating before we
even met each other so it's kind of
weird but um I want to get him I want to
get to know him better in sync was there
to madness
look at me I'm just kidding it showed up
involved their boyband glory to walk out
of here happy a success what has to
happen how'd it get all the autographs
from Santa and you don't screw up your
alliance with us don't stutter on your
Grammy goes and don't screw up the name
you know and the Grammy goes to
he's gonna say hospital as he lay in the
Oscar then there was Ricky Martin it's
Ricky Martin you want to kick off the
show business insert airing tonight
Ricky earned his first Grammy two years
earlier and performed at the show in
1999 this motivates me forthcoming this
year let's see what happens oh and
looking back a year an anniversary back
this was the spot a year ago he's right
that's right it was a very special night
I mean I guess well the position of the
moon made a lot of things happen it's
it's all about being who you are tonight
once again I have the opportunity to
perform and and I don't know it was a
very intense movement well let's see
what you know what happens tonight he
was nominated for Best Male Pop Vocal
Performance in 2000 she said amazing
intelligent woman she's very smart she's
very I mean she's ready to go and
brought a lady as his date what makes
this guy great
fabulous he's very spiritual very loving
very honest all the good things that
like we don't know already
okay so what so when you walk about it
when you walk out of here tonight you
got the Grammy in one arm who's gonna be
on the other arm anybody special man job
oh yeah yeah to tighten our uncle she's
a very special friend and I love her a
lot and if that doesn't have you totally
shook in 2000 Destiny's Child still had
four members Beyonce Kelly Michelle and
Farrah Franklin walked the red carpet in
their matchy matchy outfits everything
just worked itself out we have wonderful
stylists Stacy young and Tina no Tina
yeah we rocked we're rockin balancing on
your rockin jimmy chest
most often even in the rain but the
weather is beautiful
the girls were nominated for two Grammys
so what's gonna make this not a big big
success for y'all hopefully if we take
home at least one man and all this was
before Beyonce and jay-z were thing so
if you're walking home holding a Grammy
who's gonna be holding you well we're
gonna be holding each other safe wasn't
it that was say you have a little
special someone to celebrate with
unfortunately no I'm looking where are
you that special see another Shakespeare
they need to give him another Grammy
[Music]